if you're like me and you find yourself craving some
tangy juicy sweet and crunchy
Chinese lemon chicken
then this recipe will
knock your fkn socks off
for my dry ingredients I mixed together plain flour
cornflour salt and pepper
and then I made an egg wash by beating an egg
which really is as simple as it sounds
then I sliced about three chicken breasts up into cube shapes
before popping them through my egg wash
and dipping them into the flour
and once you're all evenly coated in the egg and flour mix
I shallow fry them in some really hot oil
and I find the trick to getting the perfect fry
is to cook them in smaller batches
and keep them moving until they're golden and crunchy on the outside
and cooked and tender in the middle
I cooked all the chicken in three batches before setting it aside
and getting started on my lemon chicken sauce
combine lemon juice soy sauce
rice wine vinegar
water sugar alongside a cornflour slurry
made from mixing 2 parts boiling water
with 1 part cornflour
I cooked it down to let it thicken up
before adding back in my fried chicken
and I let all those flavours marry together
over the heat for about a minute
and then it was time to plate up
and I just went really simple with this
and served it with some plain white rice
some sauteed wok fried veggies
sesame seeds and coriander
even the kids ate it without complaint
and that's how I know it's good